[Music]
ton thank you for joining me H startup
Nation United uh it's a special very
special different episode than what we
usually do we're here on MIT Tempest um
and uh it's November 6th today I believe
this 7th 7th already okay uh time is
lost during during everything that's
happening now H we're just over much to
the war and your work in the
consideration of the war and your
experience here you know springing into
action immediately the organization you
help form and you're leading MIT Israel
Alliance October 9th so just two days
after the war but before we get into
What's Happening Here on campus and in
general the US hey I'd love to hear
about you know what do you do outside of
the war and your graduates to here yeah
so I'm a graduate student here at MIT in
mechanical engineering I also did my
undergrad and I'm Mt in Material Science
and Engineering and music um I'm a
second year um and I study sustainable
uh Structural
Materials um yeah I do a lot of
mechanics of materials work both
experimental work and computation and
the connection with music I'm a singer
so I did a d ma music underground wow
that's incredible gu you've been already
here for for quite some time at M um in
general
you know October
7th you know going back to that very
difficult day here I guess it was a
night time right yeah when everything
transpired yeah was Friday night yeah so
I found out about what happened on
Saturday like about midday on
shat and um yeah we didn't know a lot
because it was Shabbat um so like people
were just like hearing Snippets
and stuff so we didn't find out I mean
of course like over the next few days we
found out a lot more but we were all
just pretty confused and scared and um
just in shock uh on that day um on well
me what's happening are people just on
their phones you know refreshing the
news or what sort of the energy that's
going around here doing this confusing
few days so I guess like on Shabbat like
I was at MIT kabat so we have a Kat on
campus and everyone there was just um
you know trying
to understand what was going on from
those who knew more and also just I
think there was just like a lot of
emotion like I cried and and I think
people were just in shock like people
didn't know what to believe if they it
it sounds
unbelievable um that this happened um
and and then I guess like over the next
few days it was just a mixture of
emotions um you know people cuz people
also weren't you know on their phones
for the next day for T and then you know
yeah it was just as people were getting
information people were processing
everything very differently um and I
think there's just a lot of shock that
this could happen and outside of the
Israeli and Jewish Community what was
the immediate reception from from others
because obviously here were yeah so
immediately um so I
guess the whole community of MIT and
like the Boston Cambridge
Community didn't necessarily say much um
I think for a lot of people this is just
like another conflict far away that they
don't know that much about and don't
necessarily care about um however we
have a group on campus called the
Coalition against
apartheid um which is an anti-israel
group uh and they immediately started
posting things on social media uh such
as the image I'm sure you've seen of the
Hamas fighter on town of an Israeli uh
tank and talking about the resistance
and Freedom Fighters
anded This was immediately before
anything happened you know before any
IDF Soldier stepped foot in Gaza uh so
there was already that going on and they
already started planning these rallies
and events and they most recently had a
die in um where they pretended to be
dead Palestinians so there's been a lot
of excuse me a die in a die in so in
instead of like a sit in uh they were
lying down on the ground with the names
of Palestinians who were reported to be
dead and to raise awareness um for their
cause they did this in the middle of
Lobby 7 which is the main hall at MIT so
students going to classes saw this and
they've done this but they've also done
lots of uh loud large rallies and this
is not just students coming to these
rallies they're out of the the other
people who come to these rallies are
people in the community outside of cdge
in Boston and they have some sort of a
network that brings all these people
together and they yell for inata they
all from the river to the Sea um they
talk about Israel committing genocide
apartheid ethnic cleansing colonization
etc etc um they called for one solution
into f um right over
there um which for a lot of Jewish and
Israeli students on campus the idea of
one solution reminds us only of the
final solution um so when they CH one
solution into F on our campus you can
imagine how a lot of Jewish students
were really afraid and and felt really
uncomfortable um by you know their activ
as on our
campus we we saw the different
Publications talking about the you know
Jewish
fear by by you know by Youth and and
students that's something that you felt
here the you that yeah it was a sense it
was I would imagine this know if I were
get there that thought I would feel that
way and you know when I'm looking at
this is not a traditional area of
protest this is not a traditional
building the brand or traditional campus
you know we're at MIT where where
prestigious University I was just at
staford Mile you know a few days ago and
I and I and I saw posters on the ground
stomped on and there's significance to
to the place that we're in what it
represents intellectually
ethically you know um for the community
of the world for the United States what
is how do you perceive it you know what
you know this Al the responsibility
perhaps even of of an institution like
not just MIT but in general like the top
tier
intellectual places in in the US and the
world in in relation to this conflict
and what is expected and what is not
expected yeah well I guess in terms of
the University's perspective I think
that you're seeing from a lot of these
higher level universities that they're
kind of trying to navigate yes they're
saying no to anti-Semitism and
islamophobia even though we're not
seeing any
islamophobia and so I think we've been
very frustrated by that with mit's
Administration but it is understandable
that they you know have to keep a lot in
mind especially because you know the
microscope is right on them um I think
personally um as you were talking about
I I certainly felt a
responsibility um as an MIT student who
has been here for so long and I guess
seeing the way that so many people have
via Tik Tok Instagram Etc been so easily
influenced by this anti-israel
propaganda I felt very responsible to
start the mat Israel alliance with many
other colleagues who are on the same
page as me because we want make sure you
know the people who graduate from MIT
are going to be the next tech leaders
they're going to be the next leaders in
science and biotech um you know the the
next financial leaders of the world so
it's our responsibility to make sure
that these Future Leaders don't have
these anti-israel biases or sentiments
and that if they're hearing this online
or in person that they're also hearing
you know the like our our message our
narrative and they also seeing you know
our perspective on this conflict I mean
this is really sort of a beacon right
this is a lighthouse for the world one
of the few
lighthouses and and I would imagine that
every word that's being spoken out of
mit's Campus whether it's by student
faculty member or or or an administrator
is it carries weight it carries weight
for on social media and the way that you
know anybody else it gives legitimacy to
certain types of behavior and I think
what you mentioned before and what
resonates a lot with me you know putting
aside any political perspective at all
you know having a p an experience where
a group of a group of people and
particularly given them I'm one of those
people is experiencing internal fear um
and and it's such a Beacon of Hope and
and intellectual Prestige I think that's
just a big a big moment to realize um
and I think that's why it's so it's even
more powerful the place that we are and
even more well what we're talking about
October 9th hit for being know two days
into the conflict MIT isra
lives name the choosing the name and
choosing the and and what is that what
is it all about you know tell me about
this whole thing yeah um
so as happened all around the world a
million WhatsApp groups were formed um
and people wanted to poster the
kidnapping posters were kind of coming
out and people were sending these around
um but as many universities have MIT has
roles on where you can post
you have to for example say who you are
if you put a poster up what the date is
that you postered um there's a lot of
roles around this and bureaucracy um and
also hosting events and things uh like a
rally we had a a rally and a community
vigil the week after and uh so in order
to organize all this stuff instead of
having 50 WhatsApp groups we were like
okay let's make a club let's have an
executive board let's have Point people
in trure certain things so we have you
know a social media postering chair we
have an events coordinator we have an
education coordinator Treasurer
Etc and a lot of people came together
and this is I think what's special about
the Israel Alliance is that it's a lot
of people who you know it's not just the
the people who were already active in
the Jewish or Israeli Community there
were people who before before October
7th identified as Jewish and would say
like oh I'm Jewish whatever they didn't
really care about Israel maybe even had
negative opinions about Israel but when
October 7th hit that's when a lot of
people realized if Israel didn't exist
this would happen this would happen all
over the world and there would be no
place for us to be Sav and and I had
many people come to me and say like
before this I hated Israel I thought
Israel was a you know an oppressive
colonialist whatever but now I
understand why Israel has to exist and
there those people join the MIT
and I think that we all agreed that the
main focus is education we're not here
to yell and call names um like many of
the prop Palestinian activists do um or
I I should I shouldn't say prop
Palestinian I should say
proas um and so yeah many of the proas
people are yelling they're violent um so
our goal is not to do that we it's just
not our style as you know as um MIT
people as Jewish
people you know how how does one
navigate know here there's proas around
it's hard um I mean I personally had to
leave they do they understand what
they're what they're doing you know what
they're advocating for when they're
proas I think it totally depends on the
the person um I think some people do
some people
who whatever I won't like try and make
guesses about people's backgrounds
whatever but I think some people do know
exactly what they're saying and but I
think the vast majority of these kids on
college campuses just heard something
yeah from their friend or just saw
something on Tik Tok and are like oh
yeah I guess Israel is supposed to be
bad right and they don't know what
they're talking about they just went
because their friend they went to the
rally because their friend kills them
too and then they're translating foras
exact and they don't know what they're
saying when they're saying to the from
The River To The Sea they don't know
what in means they don't know like they
don't know anything about the second in
t or what that meant for Israelis and
that goes back to rep on education as on
education exactly so that's why we're a
primarily educational organization so
this involves you know postering and and
info sessions as well as um having
guests speakers so last week we hosted
Charlotte corack from stand with us as
well as um uh Yoni Diller who is a Nova
Massacre Survivor wow and we're going to
be hosting the Palestinian human rights
activist bosam Aid um in a few weeks and
we're just hoping to bring people to
listen yeah we just want people to come
with open minds um to come and ask us
questions um so yeah that's the point of
the Israel Alliance is just to you know
show that we're not going to yell and
lash out but we are going to make our
voices hurt so time vaulting today
November 7th where are we at today
what's happening today what's the
feeling like yeah so including the other
demonstrations that I mentioned by the
Coalition against apartheid I smile
every time I say
it yes as you know there is no Israel
has come to part it's just a silly name
um for actually the organization was
created um to protest against South
Africa South African aparti which was a
real aparti yeah um and then it got the
club got renewed yeah recently to just
be anti-israel yeah I've heard that
happen in a few different universities
yeah so um recently members of this club
went to the Misty Israel offices so
Misty is a an David let me exactly so
it's an internship program and they have
them adamit and it's for all the
countries of the world pretty much um so
you know Misty Spain Misty whatever um
and it they went to the Misty Israel
offices and harassed the Misty Israel um
against guess directors there and said
like from The River To The Sea into and
they were trying to open doors they were
going from door to door trying to open
doors and I just spoke today to somebody
who was in that office an Israelite and
he said that he felt so scared to see
his people trying to unlock doors going
from door to door he felt like these are
like the terrorists coming they were
from house to house trying to open doors
trying to find people that were alive
like I don't think he feared for his
life in that same way but he was very
fearful cuz he didn't know what they
wanted what they were going to do why
were trying to unlock these doors and
this is happening on MIT I saw I saw a
video of that protest inside all it was
it was pretty aggressive and it was loud
it was aggressive it was very forceful
so I think that I would I would be
scared yeah yeah being some were those
rooms so the same people also were
yelling outside of the daycare that's at
MIT and a lot of
Israeli um faculty and postdocs and even
doctoral students who have children have
their kids in this daycare and they were
called to take their kids home early um
so it's really disruptive it's been
disruptive to people's academic and
personal lives of course um but I think
people are feeling pretty unsafe because
if they're you know visiting from Israel
for two years for a program here and
they're living on a dorm on campus they
have their kid in the daycare on campus
they don't even feel safe they don't
feel like their kid is protected they
don't feel like their office is
protected and if they're living in a
dorm on campus they don't know if
they're protected if these people are
allowed to Rong around and harass people
so um I think a lot of people are are
very
nervous um yeah about continued
harassment like that and um do we do we
know how
many Israeli or Jewish people are around
uh mat and do we have any ballpark set I
I don't know the number the hundreds
certainly certainly certainly and I
asked you this before we start recording
it you I you had looked and said what do
you mean but I'll ask it again maybe
I'll get the same STS why why why you
why are you why you enter and spring
into action in a leadership position
into this conflict heated conflict
you're obviously busy you have a lot
going
on I see that yet he chose to to to not
just participate and to be an active
member but actually take a leadership
role here you you and you mention
personality but I I don't I think that's
too simple why for you is it important
to be take a leadership Ro here I I
think a few reasons so I I guess I was
thinking to myself five years from now
when I'm looking back on this time what
would I want
to what what do I wish I would have done
I guess and and I think that if I had
sat there and let if I hadn't been an
active participant in this work as I
mentioned like it matters to me so much
how the people who are graduating from
this institution and going into very
high power positions how these people
view Israel that matters and if I hadn't
done anything or if I you know that then
I you know I just I I needed to know
that I was doing what future Talia would
would want um me to do and and also I
just think that it takes I know you said
you didn't want me to talk about the
personality thing but you know I I I
think it I I'm not Israeli and I think
that a lot of the Israelis were
very almost emotionally
incapacitated by this and
um as emotional as this is for me the
way that I am best able to deal with
things is by doing
something and
um I felt like the best way to kind of
harness everybody's emotional energy was
to help organize everybody and um I felt
like I was capable of that emotionally
at that time um and I knew that a lot of
people were just so sad they couldn't
leave their rooms they were crying all
the time they couldn't stop looking at
the news they couldn't stop watching
these videos and like I knew that the
only way to serve them and get them out
of this was to get everybody into action
and I was able to kind of have that
wherewithal in that moment um and and
many others too who comprise the
Executive Board of the MIT Israel
Alliance were also able to do that and
and it certainly wasn't all me um but
yeah I think it was just a combination
of being able to kind of harness
people's energy in a more productive way
than just anger and
sadness it's amazing thank you ER for
for both time here I love how you're
looking at it way be it sounds like
you're looking at it Way Beyond this
immediate time from the where you know
yes there's this the aspect of the
protest there this current experience
and the current subjective experience of
everybody about with the way you're
talking about education and a broader
sense the way you're talking about
future leadership the way you're
positioning the people here the human
capital that's said MIT you know this
like what I meant what I call the sort
of the beacon of of intellectual rigor
in the world and and you realize that
these are people that you know we're so
as humans perhaps we so easily
influenced when we don't know the
complexity of the situation we're so
influenced by these narratives that
through obviously through the Creator
economy and everything that's going on
on social and these are people that are
about to you know that aerating and
going to be the next leaders across
critical domains of the critical
infrastructure of society and it could
be that because of the of these types of
demonstrations that are often one-sided
and don't tell the full story they can
leave it leave still as the future Tech
leaders but uneducated on what's
Happening I think that's and that's not
something that I thought about when what
I thought we were going to what the f
were Alli and it makes a lot of sense so
thank you for for doing this and for the
sacrifices you're making for it and uh
thanks for the great thank you
[Laughter]
for